il paraît que c'est compliqué avec ta
fille en ce moment
ne sois pas triste ils me détestent
s'ils ont passé du temps ensemble faut -
la paix elle est fragile et perturbée
quand j'étais gamine nous racontait que
la vieille d'à côté était une sorcière
situe frapper à sa porte
elle venait de chercher pourtant portée
elle est revenue série ce sont des
légendes que dis-tu de ma soupe tout est
bio qui a fait ça je pensais l'ump
lycées du délire encore pourquoi par tu
le mal rôde autour d'elle impossible de
l'idée
[Musique]
huawei
sai baba yaga et des mous très anciens
elle surgit des enfers pour dévorer les
âmes innocentes
ça suffit tu deviens dingue
faites vous
fuyez